Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
It's Benjamin Dixon filling in for David.
David is a way in Los Angeles appearing on
the Joe Rogan podcast.
So I'm sure that's going to be a great conversation.
Glad to be here with you today.
Go over to the Benjamin Dickson's show on
Youtube and subscribe.
New content is up and it's my birthday, so
you know, help me get over 25,000 subscribers.
But anyway, let's get to the news.
Everything conservatives do trying to attack
Alexandria ocozzio Cortez instantly turns
into a commercial for her.
There's a tweet by a guy, a Ryan Saavedra.
Uh, he works for Ben Shapiro's daily wire
and he tweeted this out.
Um, there's two parts.
I'm going to read the tweet first and then
I want you to watch the video.
The video is a little difficult to hear, uh,
but it's worth watching.
Uh, this is what he said on Twitter.
Quote, Socialists Representative Alexandria
Kazuyo Cortez of democratic in New York on
her 93 trillion green deal.
Green new deal quote.
You have the right to a job.
You have the right to an education, you have
the right to health care, a right to a dignified
home, and a right to a dignified retirement.
Let's take a listen to that clip.
[inaudible] so,
um, here's the thing.
I find it hilarious that every single thing
Republicans think is going to be a turnoff
about Alexandria ocozzio Cortez instantly
becomes a turn on in terms of politics and
her political stance.
I want to make sure that was clear on what
I'm talking about there.
Um, but, but seriously, do you think anyone
looking at this except a sadist would look
at this and say, oh, this is just something
that we absolutely don't want.
These are things that we don't want know if
anyone has a problem with a, of having a right
to a job, a right to an education, a right
to health care, and a right to a dignified
home housing and a right to dignify retirement.
All of those things are really a part of what
the American dream always was.
Particularly for baby boomers, the baby boomer
generation, these things, we're expected a
job, a decent job, a decent education.
So anyone who looks at that and it has a problem
with it is, is, is really quite sadistic.
Uh, number one.
But number two, the only question that shouldn't
be asked about this is how do we pay for it?
Not In this Republican way.
They're like, oh, how are we going to get
this done?
But if there's any question is how do we pay
for it?
And then you look at where we're doing all
of the spending we're currently doing, particularly
on all of all of our wars, on the defense
contractors, all the money that is wasted
in our economy without even raising taxes
on the wealthy anymore than it currently is.
There's enough money that's being wasted for
us to take care of all of these things.
Not withstanding the fact that we absolutely
should raise taxes on the wealthiest people
in this country, not just because Donald Trump
just lowered them, but because they were already
historically low.
Those are the ways that we pay for these things.
That's how we get these things done.
And, and, and, and the emphasis that he puts,
uh, if you don't mind it, put it in the tweet
back on the screen from Ryan, uh, from the
daily wire.
He said Socialist representative Alexandria
Ocozzio Cortez.
First of all, bro, you're not scaring anyone
away with the word socialist anymore.
You guys kind of, you know, you guys jumped
the shark with that, with Obama when every
other sentence was a socialist mouse.
Linden is Communist.
Uh, Obama turns out, oh, everybody did.
Well, all the capitalists did well under Barack
Obama because Barack Obama was not a socialist.
Barack Obama was a capitalist, but because
you guys overplayed that card so much, nobody
looks at this and says, oh my goodness, she's
a socialist and these are terrifying things.
That's number one.
Nobody's afraid of a socialist anymore.
Thank you for that by the way.
But number two, nothing that she says here
is remotely socialism in the way that they're
trying to promote it as socialism.
I am pretty sure I've had this conversation
with this audience before, but let me emphasize
something.
Bernie Sanders and Alexandria ocozzio Cortez
are not socialists.
They are at best post office socialist.
They are FDR style capitalists.
They are trying to save capitalism from itself.
If you want to re meet some real socialist,
let me introduce you to some of my friends
who are like so far to the left of me that
they scare me, right?
There's actual communists in the country who
want to seize the means of production means
of production right away.
You know like like gulags and guilt.
Guilty right away.
Bernie Sanders and the green new deal and
Alexandria Kazuo Cortez.
This is nothing more than post office socialism
where we take a few tax dollars and we put
it together so that we can do something for
the common welfare to promote the general
welfare.
Goodness.
It's like if, if you like firefighters, then
you are a socialist according to Republicans,
right?
If you like public schools, then you're a
socialist according to Republicans.
That's because they have a fetish.
They fet assize, privatization of everything.
That is their solution to everything.
Not because they think it's going to make
it better, but because they know that they
can make a profit off of it and they know
they can take those tests.
It's not as though they want the government
to not collect the tax dollars that is currently
collecting.
Not, not, not the enterprising capitalists.
Not, not these, not the, well, I was going
to say new capitalists, but they've been doing
this for hundreds of years, but what they
want are those tax dollars to be paid to private
industry.
So private industry can do the same thing
that government would do.
But charge a little bit more and make a profit
off of it.
That's what they want, right?
So they are socialists.
They just won't.
Socialism going to the wealthy, not going
to the poor.
And so what they do is they use a scare tactic
and then say, oh, oh, because she believes
Alexandria Kazuo Cortez believes that everyone
has a right to a job.
Oh, she wants to turn America into Venezuela,
right?
A Kazuo Cortez thinks everyone has a right
to healthcare.
Oh, Venezuela.
Nevermind.
The fact that what's going on in Venezuela
is not even the result of socialism as much
as it is a result of, uh, American sanctions
and a result of the swings and oil prices
because Venezuela was overwhelmingly dependent
on oil.
But I digress.
They use that as a scare tactic so that you
can never ever demand more from this country
based on what we're putting into this country.
And based on what the wealthiest people in
this country should be putting in.
They scare you with socialism.
Venezuela, wanting a dignified retirement
is socialism and Venezuela and a Qosmio Cortez
is a socialist.
These are the games that the Republicans have
been playing for years.
And we're finally at a finally at a tipping
point where people are not terrified by those
terms anymore.
No one is going to look at a socialist and
be like, oh, this is the most terrifying thing
that I've ever seen.
And they thanks in part to yes, Bernie Sanders
being very consistent over the last, I don't
know, 30 40, 50, 60, 70 years of his career.
I love you burning.
Um, and, and thanks in part also to Republicans
using that term over and over and over again.
And now people are like, well, you know what,
if the post office is socialism to you, then
I'm okay with post office socialism and then
we should go one step further and we should
have a nationalized health care system, right?
With single payer Medicare, medicare for all
a go even further.
Like we should have a right to a job.
It is, it is very, we are, we are the wealthiest
country in the history of the world.
No reason why we cannot get every person in
this country a job.
And last but not least.
Here's, here's the, the, the, the disgusting
part about it is that every single one of
these things, uh, have the right to a job,
the right to an education, a right to healthcare,
right to a dignified home and write to a dignified
retirement.
Every single one of those things based on
how America currently is.
If we gave every American one of those things,
private industry would benefit, private industry
would get the spoils a of all of these benefits
that were given to individuals.
It will absolutely trickle up to private industry,
but that's not good enough for Republicans.
That's not good enough capitalists.
They don't want to profit off of your wellbeing.
They want to take the last dime and suck every
penny out of your life and out of your soul.
They are both teachers.
That's the irony of this is that we actually
could all do well, but they don't want that.
They would rather they do well and well, you
just, uh, good luck.